your favorite bread or bakery item could
cost you more soon as the war continues
in ukraine wheat prices are also spiking
joe moeller on this story he's live
outside of a west side restaurant with
what businesses are noticing joe
[Music]
hey their business owners are noticing a
number of products that are getting more
expensive one big one is wheat now we're
outside of bagel cafe here we spoke to
the owner here he says he's trying to
navigate these extra cars while trying
to keep his prices of his products down
every penny counts bagel cafe is a
restaurant deli and bakery they go
through a lot of flour to make all of
these items a 50 pound bag we used to
get it
16 17 now it's up to 21
owner savas andrew says while this
product is from the u.s he knows more
countries are going to be wanting that
same product now ukraine was it's the
bread basket of europe europe relies on
ukraine for wheat but without that
export countries are turning elsewhere
and driving up prices the american
bakers association says wheat prices are
up 11 percent since january and are
expected to go up even more what's
happening in ukraine what's going to
pick up that weed what is the farmers
andrews worries about how much more he
can take every day my managers were
scrambling around just to check you know
price in here and there a lot of
businesses are noticing the cost even
mothership coffee roasters in downtown
las vegas unfortunately a lot of other
companies are now sourcing american
wheat joni romero is having to get
creative this pastry container may look
empty she says they are making less to
avoid having leftovers go to waste too
many companies demanding products and
not enough products to go around both
romero and andrew say they are doing
what they can to avoid increasing their
prices how much do you charge before
they stop coming in especially now with
the fuel prices
back out here live romero says they are
using reusable cups for customers inside
the store to
save money from there as well and
they're also counting the napkins so
that none of those go to waste they're
just cutting costs where they can
reporting live joe moller live local now